so look the whole reason we're here is
i've known you forever
and uh you know timothy olmenson who's
the guest on the show today he um
he was on larry king incredible
incredible actor
and he had a stroke a couple years ago
and has been so brave and talking about
it and
like it really helps people out there
and i know that
all of a sudden i'm watching this
interview and then he says um larry king
says so who was you
who was your inspiration who inspires
you and the first thing he says is
selma blair and that's so huge
me you know it's the best um
it's the best feeling someone that you
admire their work the way they live
their life
and then they they mention your name in
any way it never
it's so flattering and this has been
huge to have to learn something so new
you know it this um
stage in the game you know and it's and
to know about him and like is such a
great recovery
he's made in that and that that's what
i'm learning too i just started
really doing really intense physical
therapy it's hard on zoom
to do pt for brain damage but
um but i but i do it and in speech
therapy and it helps
immensely so when i listen to him and
like saying he's really
recovering and it took two years really
for him to get back
to work it um made me feel so much
better because i just thought i was
going
so slow yeah with going in and out but
but as my neurologist also says brain
recovery is
it's it's such a discipline and it takes
a long time and to
see someone put in the work and do it
and talk so elegantly like he does about
it
it's i'm i'm really happy well you know
what's amazing
is i assumed he knew you why else would
you
say some no but then i thought oh my god
maybe i'm more memory lost than i think
i'm like rosie did i did i work with him
i don't know
he did xena the warrior princess but and
i did a spin-off but we didn't work
together i was cyan the warrior princess
for a minute but um
it didn't it didn't work out so i really
don't
think i did but you know i don't think
you did
you didn't i asked him for anything no i
think that you honestly
just inspired him by coming out and that
had to be hard